bonjour à tous je vous propose
aujourd'hui de suivre un colloque
organisé au sénat la semaine dernière un
colloque intitulé détruire des shs et
après alors ce colloque a été organisé
par le groupe de liaison avec les
chrétiens d'orient qui est présidé par
le sénateur bruno retailleau ainsi que
par les groupes d'amitié france irait et
france irak
l'objectif est bien c'est d'explorer les
voies d'une réorganisation politique au
moyen-orient pour tenter d'esquisser ce
que pourrait être une sortie de crise en
syrie
voilà je vous propose tout de suite
d'écoutés l'introduction de ce colloque
par le président du sénat gérard larcher
messieurs les ministres et je voudrais
saluer plus particulièrement jean pierre
chevènement qui étaient ici présents
hervé de charette
hubert védrine va nous rejoindre dans
quelques minutes
monsieur le président du groupe de
liaison de réflexion de vigilance et de
solidarité avec les chrétiens d'orient
cher bruno retailleau
monsieur le président du groupe d'amitié
france irak du sénat sert bernard cazeau
je voudrais à cet instant a excusé jean
pierre vial président du groupe d'amitié
france syrie qui a beaucoup oeuvré pour
ce colloque il est en convalescence les
nouvelles sont bonnes je les ai eus au
téléphone et il vous transmet à la fois
son amitié la fidélité de son engagement
total pour ce que vous allez partager
tout au long de cette journée
messieurs les ambassadeurs mes chers
collègues députés et sénateurs jouent à
gérard bapt
au premier rang on a partagé des choses
ensemble dans une vie antérieure
je voudrais saluer monseigneur gollnisch
et salué le professeur riccardi avec une
différence particulière car j'ai le
souvenir il ya maintenant cinq ans
d'avoir échangé santé j diot à
l'occasion d'un déplacement officiel et
je dois dire que nous aurons avec michel
mercier dans peu de temps
aussi à faire des choses ensemble pour
pour le dialogue et même si le monde a
beaucoup changé en cinq ans monsieur le
professeur
je crois que les valeurs santé vidéo
reste des valeurs particulièrement
indispensable pour pour le dialogue et
je voulais vous souhaitez vraiment la
bienvenue
mesdames et messieurs ce tag rente
honneur oui honneur qui m'étonnait ce
matin d'ouvrir ce colloque organisé à
l'initiative des groupes d'amitié france
irak francs syrie du sénat ainsi que du
gros bras de liaison que leur président
tous trois en soit remercié mais sur ce
colloque n'aurait pu voir le jour sans
l'appui de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées
je voudrais aussi saluer l'action de son
président jean pierre raffarin qui nous
étions encore hier soir et vous voyez
tout est possible cher jean pierre
chevènement à recevoir président de la
commission des affaires étrangères du
conseil de la fédération de russie pour
échanger ensemble sur un certain nombre
de sujets que vous allez encore évoquer
tout au long de la journée tout à
l'heure monseigneur louis sako va va
nous rejoignent
son témoignage est attendu je voudrais
remercier mon seigneur gollnisch d'avoir
accepté aussi de participer à ce
colloque
il a six un rassemblement pour soulager
la souffrance des chrétiens et de tous
ceux qui quels que soient leurs
convictions subissent la violence et
dois vous dire que avec la délégation
aux droits des femmes du sénat
j'ai reçu l'évoqué avec monsieur
l'ambassadeur d'irak
j'ai reçu de 18 février dernier et
madame nadia mourad cette jeune femme
yazidi enlevé par des ch dont le récit
est et bouleversant christiane
kammermann était avec moi ce colloque
n'aurait pas toute sa portée bien
entendu si nous mettions pas en
perspective je suis heureux rossellat de
la république
on puisse se mêler la parole d'hommes de
foi imminent à celle des diplomates des
responsables politiques ou des
chercheurs c'est aussi cela la laïcité
quand j'ai toujours revendiqué sans
adjectif
en ce qui me concerne mesdames et
messieurs une leur d'espoir certes
encore très frêle n'est aujourd'hui en
syrie en irak en syrie une trêve je sors
d'une rencontre avec le chef
d'état-major de nos armées ce matin avec
lequel je fais un poids régulier une
trêve cessez le feu fragile entre les
parties combattant l'islamisme l'état
islamique et à nostra en irak parce que
la progression de l'état islamique est
interrompue voire inverser cette lueur
d'espoir restent ténus alors que
l'emprise de cet état islamique en libye
se développent et développe aujourd'hui
des ramifications en afrique
c'était bien une des préoccupations nous
avons partagé ce matin il nous faut donc
faire face à nos responsabilités
le chaos en syrie en irak est le fruit
d'un échec collectif de la communauté
internationale c'est aussi un immense
gâchis dans cet échec la france avec
d'autres assume sa part de
responsabilité en matière de diplomatie
les meilleures intentions ne produisent
pas les meilleurs résultats
je ne souhaite pas m'appesantir sur le
passé je souhaite seulement souligner
qu'il ne s'agit pas simplement d'un
débat intellectuel
nous parlons de vies brisées de femmes
d'hommes et d'enfants au destin qui
parfois s'arrête sur une plage sur la
côte turque ou des rivages de la côte
italienne et les décisions prises à
l'abri des chancelleries ont des
conséquences graves
les pays occidentaux n'ont pas vu venir
des ch
c'est d'ailleurs difficile de faire le
diagnostic pourquoi
nous avons procédé à une évaluation
erronée de la situation sur le terrain
en syrie
souvenons nous on a annoncé à maintes
reprises l'effondrement d'un régime
toujours en place et le triomphe d'une
opposition dans la faiblesse égale les
ambitions de renault
ça n'était pas hier siégions sont les
mêmes dans jean pierre chevènement et
moi la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées et nous l'entendions déjà nous
avons longtemps choisi d'exclure de la
table de négociation certains acteurs
qui de fait était majeure et sur
lesquelles un règlement du conflit de
toute évidence s'est avéré impossible
nous sommes attachés à des chimères ou
des illusions en répétant que si
l'histoire s'est érodée rouler
différemment si les frappes aériennes
avaient été menées à l'été 2013 tout
aurait été comme par miracle le régler
la réécriture de l'histoire avec des
scies ne fait pas l'histoire
bref si naturellement nous n'avons pas
été à l'origine de la crise nous avons
de fait accusé les effets on devrait
d'ailleurs parlé non d'une crise mais
d'un empilement de crise la répression
féroce menée par le régime de bachar al
assad
la relégation de populations sunnites en
irak aux marches du pouvoir et de la
société voilà pourquoi il faut réussir à
tout prix l'inclusion qui prendra du
temps mais sans cette inclusion on ne
progressera pas y compris au plan
militaire et vous ne savez bien tribune
du général de villiers nous renvoie que
le militaire n'est qu'un moyen mais
n'est pas en soi la solution et que la
solution est toujours politique après
les moyens militaires il ya les
violences de la guerre les populations
qui fuient la terreur de dèche et ceux
qui au lieu de combat qui terrorise se
combattent entre eux